seventeen-year-old malala yousafzai is
the youngest person to ever win a nobel
prize
she is also the first pakistani to win
the peace award
she shares this year's prize with fellow
children's rights activist kailash
satyati
those attending applauded the two
recipients for their selfless work
the prize committee commended malala for
her clear vision and tireless courage
malala yosef sai's vision was clear
right from the start
girls have a self-evident right to
education
her courage
is almost
indescribable
malala grew up in northern pakistan
since an early age she spoke out in
support of girls rights and against the
extremist ideology of local taliban
groups but her advocacy nearly cost her
her life
in 2012 a taliban soldier boarded her
school bus and then shot her three times
in the head
malala barely survived
her heroic survival made international
headlines she has used her story to
bring attention to her cause
it is for those
forgotten children
who want education
it is for those
frightened children
who want peace
it is for those
voiceless children
who want change
this year's prize is being split between
a hindu man and muslim woman from two
very different backgrounds but both
satyathi and yusuf sai share the same
dream to live in a world where all
children are free